why does that why did the universe have
the Big Bang to express itself in all
the possible combinations of like you
know this size star with one planet at
this distance okay same size star with
two planets the dryads plays out all the
possible combinations and there's
probably even multiple Big Bang's that
are playing out lots of other different
variables of physics and quantum
realities and whatnot and perhaps one
saying I was whispered all this is just
consciousness trying to understand
itself by playing out all the possible
scenarios all the edge cases it's sort
of like you could say white light is
split in this prism just to map out all
its component pieces and so perhaps the
reason it goes that prism to get sharted
out and all these different
configurations is to dance with
uncertainty yes you know that to create
a little bit of like action and
uncertainty and mystery you know we have
platforms coming out of Silicon Valley
that is directly affecting the behavior
is the perception of every human being
on the planet with that comes a level of
responsibility that I think sometimes we
shook here we've also been innovating
non-stop on this you know kind of
manifest destiny thing would just make
it faster cheaper better free returns
less shipping take out all the friction
for the sake of more convenience more
choice more instant gratification more
speed more scale the hidden price of
convenience is you lose connection with
the thing you made convenient I love
that you brought up the food example
went meat does it make a nugget do you
know where it came from you don't even
know what the chicken like you have no
idea and you can't care has been so
abstracted from the source because we're
now in the era where it's about AI and
write rate data those and the the talent
that work on AI as the new oil and gold
ores and their scarce resources those
are the new battlegrounds of supremacy
you can see a dystopian future where
three or four mega mega corporations run
everything
interestingly I have a bizarro parallel
universe in China where they have their
big three or four if we could charge
ahead with tech with the wisdom of you
know historic humanity as well I think
that
nice compliment and you know we started
the podcast was basically refined the
questions keep questioning the system
and try to explore and build new models
for the future I kind of think a lot
about perhaps we weave this cognition of
death more and more into our everyday
and knowing how to die well perhaps
gives clues of how to live well that's a
really good doorway to this Wow and a
lot of it really starts with self love
you know that's the doorway to capacity
for infinite love for everybody what if
god is that capacity with us to have
that same intensity and depth of
compassion and empathy and love for all
beings for nature of everything else
around us you know a vast infinite sort
of sea of all-encompassing love no
someone's opinion may contradict yours
what is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we and what is
the nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don Sathyan we are on-site in Menlo
Park California at Mayfield we are now
going to be talking about Wow and why
that's greater than why we have Tim
Chang joining us on the show hi Tim hi
good morning it's great to be here
thanks so much for coming on the program
thank you we're so honored we're very
grateful very pumped conversation yeah
Liz I don't know Tim's background he's a
partner at Mayfield fund investing in
next-gen Commerce and marketplaces
communities health and wellness and
digital media has been twice named to
the forbus Forbes Midas list and the
always-on power players of top investors
as well as receiving the special
achievement award from the gamification
summit for his work in leveraging game
design thinking tim has led early-stage
investments creating more than 2.6
billion in total exit value sits on the
board of myriad companies is a bass
guitarist in two bands and aims to bring
a WoW to each moment
you can find his links in the Bible or
to his Mayfield page as well as Twitter
Instagram and LinkedIn check those out
everyone Tim we have been so fascinated
with understanding the nature of this
reality what do you think honestly with
each passing day I think I have more
questions than answers and I think
that's okay I come to conclusion I think
the the process of refining the
questions maybe is the answer this
process perhaps is the real point of
this whole journey right and I don't
know it's funny because as I as I keep
learning I just keep going back to these
aphorisms and sayings that have been
around with us for a long time and seem
really trite and almost fortune-cookie
like but they're just so right basic
ones like know thyself or as above so
below
or another way I've heard it said is as
within is expressed without you know all
these things another one I heard with a
group that I've been working on there's
we've been thinking about this value of
small is all meaning what you do in each
moment is reflective of then how you
express yourself in all the other
moments so it's sort of like the micro
leads to the macro I see it expressed in
what I do here at work because what I'm
realizing is that startups companies
institutions we build they're really
just extensions amplifications of the
intention the energy the values of the
founding people all right and in that
way culture never really happens by
accident I mean it can be emergent like
if you don't define what you want your
culture to be it will emerge you know
likely be reflection of the values the
energy the intention or lack thereof of
the people behind it right and so it's
all a very fractal pattern that these
seeds that come from within in terms of
what our intention what are our
alignment is our energy if you will not
to sound too woo about it but just kind
of has those ripple effects that ripple
outward in these concentric shells these
fractal patterns that keep magnifying a
different that different layers of
magnification orders of magnitude
we're constantly refining the questions
yes we're in this process is the purpose
of this being made for us to go through
the symphonic artistic process I love
that that phrase you used okay so in a
deep deep meditation I once did this
image came in to me and it it really
kind of spelled a lot of for me in terms
of this framework imagine just beautiful
glorious all-encompassing white light
and it is made of all the different hues
and colors and if you were to split it
out you know in a prism you would
separate out all the possible
combinations all the the permutation is
the different hues and saturations and
and whatnot and each of them is as
unique and brilliant as the others just
as valid but the Assembly of all of them
you know the complete codex of all these
colors makes up white light and so one
could argue that let's say why did the
why did the universe have the Big Bang
to express itself in all the possible
combination of combinations of like you
know this sized star with one planet at
this distance okay the same sized star
with two planets the right it plays out
all the possible combinations and
there's probably even multiple Big
Bang's that are playing out lots of
other different variables of physics and
and quantum realities and whatnot and
perhaps someone's saying I was once
heard all this is just consciousness
trying to understand itself by playing
out all the possible scenarios all the
edge cases it's sort of like you could
say white light is split into this prism
just to map out all its component pieces
maybe in a similar way consciousness
represents itself in all the Allens and
Timms out there because there's a
certain Ellen is only you can express
right and you know it's playing all of
these possible scenarios out to map out
that possibility space wonderful short
story by Jorge Louie for case that is
called the library of Babel that also
explains this in different format
picture an infinite repeating library of
these hexagonal chambers right made up
of identical bookshelves identical
layouts and in it identical sized books
just for eternity and there's one book
out there and all it says is aaaa and
there's another book next to us is a a a
B onwards onwards onwards until Z zzzzzz
and then contain with that library is
every possible story in every possible
you know language in that alphabet and
and so that's another way of framing the
same thing yeah yes they're such good
ways of putting it so consciousness
adventuring out to understand itself to
be at play in these symphonies through
this art can be viewed through this
source white light breaking up through a
prism with all the hues and saturations
it can be viewed as this library of just
starting with just the A's all the way
to just the Z's and all the different
combinatoric scan be viewed in the
multiverses that are unfolding yeah and
within that is all the range of
possibilities in that one universe and
then the funny thing is you could have a
library Babel that has different sized
shelves and books and that would be a
whole different universe in itself so
you have a universe of universes or the
so-called multiverse right and I like
that you bring up the word play so I
think that's ultimately what this is all
about
it's a giant dance um I remember you
know some occasions tapping into that
source consciousness that white like
Java that's for a little fleeting moment
and realizing how grand and wonderful
and
all-encompassing it was but then also
kind of cooing into hey this could be
kind of boring too because when you're
everything at all possibilities at once
there's nowhere to go there's nothing to
do you're everything it's it's it's all
infinity contained and so perhaps the
reason it goes that prism to get sharted
out and all these different
configurations is to dance with
uncertainty yes you know to create a
little bit of like action and
uncertainty and mystery there's another
great quote I once heard it is what
departed like to tell the living is that
the thing they missed the most
outside of ice-cream is the delicious
mystery of uncertainty yeah you know
and you know this is the stuff that
drives humans nuts we don't know our
brains hate uncertainty because they are
survival program machines to try to
figure and predict things out have
causal narrative all you know clearly
cut a versus B black versus white visual
versus one we try to minimize
uncertainty as a survival instinct but
really you know uncertainty is you could
argue the spice the joy the point of
life you don't know what's gonna arise
yeah so to go through all these
combinatorics to be at play with the
uncertainty unfolding throughout all of
them yeah also another good one that we
liked is that this is where you can feel
the illusion of separation mm-hmm yes
have you read that short story the egg
by Andy weir you know wash I have them
on the program yeah such a fan that
story because that's another wonderful
sort of short metaphor for the same kind
of framework we're talking about yes yes
yeah would you say that the all that
we're discussing right now these
feelings of oneness and play
interconnectedness love would you say
that our disconnection from that is the
most upstream issue that we face yeah I
I think so this illusion of separation
you know at the core of it what I keep
wondering is what does any human really
really want yes they want you know lack
of suffering and the whole Maslow's
hierarchy of needs but the root root
thing people want is to be seen in
witnessed and acknowledged in that sense
of connection and community right I
think what it is is going against that
sense of separation right it's it's like
returning to that communal feeling these
are things search used to provide and
now you know the modern church doesn't
have that same context but we're trying
to synthesize alternatives whether it's
Burning Man or raves or cuddle puddles
or whatever it is things that bring us
back to a sense of connection you know
those fleeting moments where it's like
wow I am you you are me we are
we're all sort of connected we're
different reflections of each other you
know one of my favorite exercises to do
that too is um you know next time you're
at a dinner party or a small gathering
when you go around for self
introductions instead of you know who
you are on what you do and that sort of
thing
Keith Francie once taught me this but go
around and say okay your name and what
is the single biggest thing that you are
wrestling or struggling with in life
right now and what's interesting is by
the third or fourth person people are
just spilling their guts they're getting
really raw and authentic and vulnerable
and what that taught me is vulnerability
is the ultimate bonding superpower and
by time you go around the table what's
kind of marvelous is you realize holy
cow we're all wrestling with the same
five or six things just in different
formats and framings and that in a way
feels very there's strong sense of
relief there because you're like oh I'm
not alone in this struggle we all dance
with the same challenges Wow
vulnerability and feelings of community
bonding around these very similar
challenges that we face really like that
activity a lot and it does seem as
though we are very much so gravitating
our energies towards these examples that
you listed of waste weather cuddle
puddles or burning man's or even just
trying to redesign cities and
communities around men circles women
circulates best types of things and so
that's is that then the architectures
the designs that we hope to put into the
social fabric of the future yes I love
the organ there okay so now we can
intersect with where this is all heading
in terms of future work future of play
future cities future families all these
different systems and institutions we've
had until now and are getting rapidly
disrupted with new technologies you know
kind of new ways of being more
reconnection with self and each other we
have long blamed technology for you know
this sort of disconnection with
ourselves we're living looking at our
screens and that sort of thing I like to
say though technology is not an enemy
it's just a tool
and so like with all tools you know it's
um a hammers not bad it's the intention
you do that you want a hammer to build a
birdhouse you want a hammer to go whack
someone to the head it is all about the
energy and the intention you bring to it
so Tech is not the enemy per se it's our
mindless or mindful application of it
which is the difference and so one thing
I have noticed that the evolution the
history of technology if we peel back in
zoom out you know Silicon Valley
historically when it first started was
building a lot of widgets literally
semiconductors and parts and pieces that
would go into other technologies so was
often tech companies selling to other
tech companies fairly limited in scope
or people that reached on a direct basis
then branched more into things like
enterprise software and applications and
so Silicon Valley we had startup selling
tools products services to other
businesses so you're reaching workers
employees whatnot then we had you know
through the late 80s and 90s
technologies that was touching every
consumer you know we had platforms
coming out of Silicon Valley that is
directly affecting the behavior is the
perception of every human being on the
planet with that comes a level of
responsibility that I think sometimes we
shook here in the valley we love to say
like I'm a platform I don't know the
content on it frankly I think that's a
cop-out yes I know why it's because when
you're at that scale you can't manage
the headache of sort of like MA during a
discussion but when is a tech platform
you do become the mass media you do
become the retail store shelf you do
become the arbiter of truth then you
have to step up with that responsibility
out there you can't just say no I don't
know go through my pipes I'm just a pipe
right and so that's something I think we
need to step up for here we've also been
innovating non-stop on this you know
kind of manifest destiny thing I've just
make it faster cheaper better free
returns less shipping take out all the
friction for the sake of more
convenience more choice more instant
gratification more speed more scale the
problem with that is we have costs with
that we hadn't thought about with that
other externalities that we've created
with that something I worry about now is
that the the the price the hidden price
of convenience is you lose connection
with the thing you made convenient this
is a very profound point
and so like where the food actually
comes yeah yeah yeah yeah this is a big
one
that's why conveniens is making it so
that we don't care so much about the
source right about the supply chain
there you go yeah exactly
and with that then once you lose
connection with that source you could
lead to a lot of like mindless
consumption you could lead to what I
think frankly is like zombie like
behavior where you're just addicted
these dopamine drips of hits of
notifications of you know
retail therapy gratification instant get
this on-demand right and I love that you
brought up the food example when meat is
they make a nugget do you know where it
came from you don't even know if it's a
chicken like you have no idea and you
don't care has been so abstracted from
the source that there's a button and the
drone delivers it to me right and even
with the on-demand economy you click a
button a car shows up sometimes I can be
dehumanizing to the workers too right
we've built all these products and
services for these top one percenters
living in urban centers like San
Francisco in New York and the point is
almost minimize human connection hit a
button leave the package there go away
don't bother me you know it's almost
like factoring out human connection and
so if technology 1.0 was all about this
drive towards more convenience less
friction it's created this abundance
reality we have which i think is making
us very unhappy because now we have more
content than you consume in a lifetime
more games and any one person could ever
play more calories and anyone could
rightly or healthily consume in a day
you know all this stuff that is
available to us now this abundance of
choices which actually creates a lot of
stress because our brain still have the
neural programming of when we were
running around the steps of Africa and
and just trying to survive in a threat
field scarcity environment that's why
your tongue seek calorie dense foods our
eyes are looking for novelty our minds
are always looking for simple heuristic
causal narratives we're looking for
anything that gives us an edge for
procreation that almost explains any
humans behavior in any one moment does
this help me procreate don't get eaten
eat and pass on my genes right and so
we've got that scarcity mindset but now
what's living in this like huge
abundance filled you know choice
cornucopia and the two don't match that
impedance mismatches driving us
literally crazy we're little battle in
our biology and our neural programming
to get through each day hence we need
things like fasting and we need tech
Shabbats and we need you know anti-tech
addiction and we have we need more
mindfulness because we're basically
trying to curb our impulses in this sort
of candy store of infinite choices right
I feel like modern people it's like
you're it's like you're you're a crack
addict and you've been handed a crack
pipe for the administer plies okay
self-regulate right so maybe tech 2.0 is
about helping us manage those impulses
and become better people the people we
want to be you know starting with more
connection with ourselves and each other
but also maybe limiting some of these
impulses may be reducing choice may be
reducing the need for so much willpower
maybe even you know reducing friction
and convenience you know people think
I'm nuts when I say that but I wonder if
the next act of technology is
introducing more helpful friction more
intentional you know inconvenience to
make us more reconnected with ourselves
with supply chain with each other with
mother nature with where things come
from you know because you know isn't
that that saying you really care about
what you have to work for right and I
was talking to Tommy the other day you
know it came from Google X and he had
this really great point that we're
living in an age where everything is so
well curated you know events and
settings and whatnot and it's all made
for Instagram ability right so it looks
all great but combine that with
convenience is all about it looks great
I didn't have to do anything for it but
I worry that that creates this
sugar-coated surface that a head doesn't
have meaning you know so I guess
sometimes go to events or festivals and
everything's so well curated and I
didn't have to lift a finger and it's
all about like I hung it myself you're
just right and I forget I've even been
there after a month
as opposed to when you really have to
work at something when you have to sync
blood sweat and tears into it that
investment creates this emotional true
connection with it creates meaning
creates purpose and so I'm wondering if
that's what we've siphoned out of a lot
of our experiences is that
investment that work that we have to put
into something to derive that meaning
and purpose which flies in the face of
instant gratification convenience very
well should the sized so what I'm
basically saying is like at my next
birthday party it'll probably have
engineered adversity and challenge in
there to make people really bra and
bonds through shared adversity and
struggle and and vulnerability hey I
love this way of explaining modernity
having so much frictionless instant
gratification dopamine drips Instagram
abilities where there's not so much of
the indigeneity aspects of blood sweat
and tears of actually building the
building that you live in or planting
the food and then fun than fostering it
and then enabling it to produce you the
food that you eat that these ways of
viewing a redesign of our social fabric
that that focuses more on the connection
to each other to mother earth that that
seems to be a part of it
I hear that and also just yesterday
talking with Kevin Kevin Kelly on the
program this whole idea of a Technium
this whole idea of where everything's
heading in several hundred or even a
thousand years we were discussing about
well will there will there be with all
given all the combinatorics and
permutations of technologies and
artificial intelligences and all this
other type of stuff that can
self-replicate may it may be that
certain people never look at other
people in the eyes or that they never
plant a seed and grow it and eat the
apple from the tree yeah so does it feel
like those two things harmonize both the
reconnecting but also the further
Technium this is something I think about
a lot I almost feel like it's this
interesting parallel race condition
between these two sort of forces and
what I always kind of come back to is it
feels like there's one set of forces
that drives towards convergence
centralization there's another set of
forces that drives towards divergence
each decentralization and the trick
might be finding the harmony and
interplay between both but in many ways
I feel like these extremities are
pushing even more outwards more
vehemently right
maybe we can riff on this for a bit I
think about is the nature of AI about
the ultimate form of centralization I
hope not because I could put the
ultimate gatekeepers in in you know
power right
as it stands we've got you know these
three or four mega platforms that are
centralizing all the proprietary data
owning all the information controlling
all the forms of business and commerce
out there right now because we're now in
the era where it's about AI and
proprietary data those and the the
talent that work on AI as the new oil
and gold those and those scarce
resources those are the new
battlegrounds of sort of supremacy right
and so when you have Google Facebook
Amazon controlling wide swaths of all
these businesses you could see a
dystopian future where three or four
mega mega corporations run everything
interestingly I have a bizarro parallel
universe in China where they have their
big three or four right so they're
playing out 1984 we're playing out brave
new world out here right kind of
different directions at the same time
this reconnection with nature I feel
like is more about self-sufficiency and
decentralization just a small example
it's not not a perfect example but the
one upside of all these wildfires in in
Marin is one all you know rich
privileged people finally got a taste of
climate change so we're like oh this is
real but what it's really made people
think of is oh my gosh I might have to
take matters in my own hands instead of
just relying on convenient centralized
grid PG&E maybe I should get solar maybe
I should
be self-reliant from my energy needs
what else should I be self-reliant in
case I can't count on the central grid
as climate collapse starts tick again
right maybe what that creates is more
mindfulness and more hands-on action -
like we talked about not just rely on
the outsourced convenience of like some
other centralized platform but to be
more self-reliant I should probably get
solar I should probably get a power wall
I should probably be able to be you know
net neutral on energy production
consumption huh what if I did the same
for water or what if I did the same for
food right so it could be this
decentralization back to sort of
self-sufficiency which would entail more
mindfulness of where your energy your
water your utilities come from where
your food comes from
maybe heightens interest in being sort
of self producing on those on those
aspects as well because you know in the
era of doordash and ubereats and all
these other things we've abstracted and
out sourced at all and so maybe the
pendulum swings the other way and it's
time to reconnect with all those things
we've made convenient right Wow to me it
also feels like with what you're talking
about regarding centralization of
artificial intelligences and mega
corporations and decentralization of
self-sufficiency
those also feel like the yin and yang of
modernity and indigeneity yeah yeah yeah
that's a better that's a good way to
look at that lens I'm really interested
in studying indigenous wisdom again
because I just feel like there's this
notion of going backwards to the future
there's so much wisdom that you know
kind of traditional people's got right
that especially connection with nature I
think in with each other there's rites
of passage there's rituals so it's
cultural context that we've lost sight
of that
I think we're hungry to bring back in
right and that applies for lots of areas
whether it's community building
spirituality you know how we use plant
medicines all those sorts of things you
know we're charging ahead with tech but
we got to make sure not to dehumanize it
if we could charge ahead with tech with
the wisdom of you know historic humanity
as well I think that would be a nice
compliment that's a great way to put it
yeah charge charge ahead with
the way with this Dow a while also
remembering and integrating some of the
99.9% of our human existence
pre-enlightenment pre-industrial
revolution that actually has some of the
most important codes so that's been a
way that we've left up in a lens that
we've been looking at this with that we
think is potentially one of the biggest
keys for a prosperous future and I'm
curious what your thoughts are about
this well you've talked about this
before yeah really I really like this
idea of of once you hear the message
hang up the phone so once you do have
these feelings of of oneness we kind of
run to sometimes we run to the next peak
experience we can see a phenomenon
happening we also see people that ask
the question well Tim if you and Alan
are so one already why even have this
podcast why even share with the world
one so honey how do you balance this
idea of effortless action this in this
desire to be a part of the DAO yeah
effortless in in in action you don't
take action effortless in action yeah in
balance that with architecting a
prosperous social fabric yeah great
question I'm gonna share a bit about my
own personal story is you know sort of a
lot of these explorations began for me
self inquiry what not probably good ten
years ago and kind of ramped up from
there and you know a couple years ago I
definitely had a peak experience sort of
I'll call it scratching on the doorway
of enlightenment for just a fraction of
a second and within that kind of for me
saw how oh this is the matrix right this
is a little more than a simulation and
it was beautiful tapping into source
consciousness but afterwards a little
bit terrifying and what I mean by that
is
upon so-called awakening a lot of times
what we don't realize is that there can
be a nihilistic downward slope of that
as well because you could also say well
hey if this is all a simulation why the
heck do anything at all if it doesn't
mean anything
there's no point then why do anything
there was a woman I consider like let's
go phone when Astrid goes to the top of
the mountain and just you know meditate
24 hours a day because everything else
is just monkey games chasing pointless
things to reproduce and pass on genes
and I do wonder maybe that's why some
mystics or or legendary you know
enlightened folks didn't bother having
families or children they did go for
monastic can just go disappeared to the
mountaintops right that's one way to
play the game he's sort of saying oh
it's a video game done playing out of
here
um you know the other one is maybe it's
then coming back down the mountain to
just be of service you know not to be a
preacher be a guru or prescribe anything
but just to maybe be a living example
that so-called be the change you want to
see in the world right um your point
though on peak experience chasing one
thing I worry about a lot with you know
current times is that with psychedelic
culture with all these other things
around you know consciousness hacking
and whatnot there are a lot of people
that are seeking those peak experiences
and I get it it's a kind of high or it
could be from a spiritual bypass you
know I know of people who are going off
for their you know twenty eighth
ayahuasca sitting within three months
and you know it sort of makes me wonder
when eighteen the time to integrate
those lessons you know you're on the
phone all the time you get the downloads
but when you gonna hang up the phone and
start living those values right thank
you you know you get these peak
experiences and you get the call so to
speak to jump into that world or maybe
you yourself wanna go be
and help change the world but in moments
that I've wrestled with that I always
caught myself that wow there's a lot of
ego speaking there and the biggest smack
in my face was like actually - you don't
have to do anything or tell anybody
anything or sell or preach or evangelize
anything just trying to be a beer right
with your smallest micro remember those
fractal moments as within as you express
without every footstep every heartbeat
every thought every moment every word
said is not for tuna t to be that and so
and serve as kind of just a living
invitation for that right and eventually
somebody may come up to you say hey man
something's different about you it's
going on and it's a chance to free to
share your story and if it you know
opens Pandora's Box great you know yeah
and then maybe you've leave some
breadcrumb trails with some well curated
questions there's a place to advise yeah
and that helps somebody go down their
own the rabbit hole right and so that's
that's kind of a thing I'm I'm thinking
a lot about is its power to just kind of
come back down that mountain and not
just sort of chase the spiritual BiPAP
have a bypass path or a gofal monastic
so to speak and find ways you know to be
of service but again without necessarily
proscribed agenda a lot of us also
battle with I want to save the world
syndrome and my good friend of all raava
comm once said to music you know I all
the strife in the world today it's not
super villains or evil people you know
doing bad things no one ever thinks of
themselves that way is basically white
knights clashing with each other on who
can save the world the best right and so
good intentions right it's everybody has
their good intentions or saying my
journey should be your journey yeah as
opposed to you know your mileage may
vary
you know I'll share my story hopefully
it helps right all of us have our unique
communions with that one yeah so back to
the white light and the color now as we
imagine like purple number 32 trying to
explain to red 18 you need to be purple
number 32 this is how it works raises
house best be for you as opposed to you
know we've got similar hues of some you
know red and blue in there but this is
totally different
I'll have no idea what your path was
like but man it's cool you know it's
respecting the full inner unique journey
of the snowflake or of that artist or of
that instrument being played in the
symphony in its full uniqueness of that
full hue or saturation of the rainbow
that that being a mean of me part of
this I also I also I also really really
appreciate how your you're able to both
have a strong understanding of this
these analogies and metaphors for the
oneness and the uniqueness and the
perfection but also see that there's a a
calling for one that immerses themselves
in that feeling of oneness to not just
in a sense go to the mountain but
immerse themselves in a sense in in the
in their state of being not with the
mountain but being in the civilization
where they themselves create a butterfly
effect around them with their family the
friends their communion and then
catalyze further inner artists to be
unleashed in the grand symphony thank
you for that reflection that's a great
way to freeze in frame it I think it's
sort of dancing with Kenya to be yes and
it skidded like I came from the hardcore
rationalist side I started to dance with
the mystical but is there something that
can blend into both of your wisdoms from
both right um so so with that journey
you know for a year after sort of that
awakening moment I had the hardest time
because I was losing motivation I'd be
sitting in meetings and I'd be almost
laughing my cells like you guys you're
screaming about each other at these like
monkey brain game sort of things to me
was akin to watching like a ten-year-old
spaz out at the video game screen and
start chucking things around and part of
me is like video game waiting so upset
all right well you're optimizing these
things right um and I it was tough
because I was like oh my gosh what if I
have no vision left this is that
so-called dark night of the soul period
right when you're questioning everything
and don't have that Nordstrom compass
and it took me a while just float and
sit with it until I realized
ah okay just because nothing what it
means anything doesn't mean you can't
have some fun with it you can't play
with it you can't do some good with it
and so really what I've come down to now
is like okay fine if it's all the matrix
and there's no point then maybe the
point is this is all about art it's
about expression and it's about perhaps
service and in helping each other so
that's ricki not doing this sounds super
trite but it's like what's the point
love that's it right so love of yourself
and finding your voice the form of play
it's love and form of self healing the
trauma and wounds you had then love in
the form of taking that super power of
yours that makes you feel most alive
most vibrant sharing it the world but
love and the phone was sharing that
plate in a service to more than just you
right and that I think could be a really
beautiful life so it's sort of like all
right fine that's all the video game but
I'm no longer just chasing points and
badges and achievements and level ups I
think I'll just play for the fun of it
and have
maybe help others play right and that
makes much more sense to me that's
impacted how I've even invested here
Mayfield because Alan I realized I had a
lot of karmic identity prepay because a
lot of my initial success came in the
worlds of places like gaming social
media and tech other things that I don't
know we're net net good for Humanity or
for mental well-being or spiritual
health or those sorts of things right
you mentioned I had that gamification
award I grew up playing programming you
know computer games and really studying
them inside now and then leveraging
those design principles frankly a lot of
times to try to hack engagement you know
I remember sitting around in board
meetings I'm not proud of saying this
now but we'd sit around talk about how
to you know kind of predict users right
and so I now have a new filter which is
I would look at any startups that aren't
good for Humanity and that blocks a lot
of things out and I'm looking at you
tick-tock but you know I had told my
partner's I'm careful tick-tock makes a
hundred billion dollars I think it's one
of those deadly things on the planet
right now for Humanity I've been
algorithmically generated content to
maximize engagement for addiction to
drive more ads right in real-time
responsiveness that's one of the
essentially deadly forms a hey I can be
leveraged if AI is turned around to add
ictus creator you know with with
real-time emergent media and just create
this infinite echo chamber right driven
by business model that's primarily just
for driving more advertising we have to
look at the systems and the business
models we use for these businesses I
don't think the people that take dr.
evil I think we just optimize for the
business models that we're driving for
it's time to upgrade our playbook of
what business models we use they can't
just be more about Oh more engagement
more sessions more ads that's one I
won't do any
so free and ad-based I just won't look
at in the second model would be just
produced more consume more this is sort
of the classical mentality of by by the
palette and yeah most of it ends up in
your garage and not used but you saved
20% you know so that's sort of like
endless growth-oriented you know
consumptive capitalist model so it's
made me really think a lot about the
underlying systems and models we use and
why it's time for a firmware upgrade
from any of these things and it seems
like the main principle of that firmware
upgrade is the style of immediate return
hunter/gatherer that was symbiotic with
its environment in symbiotic with one
another which is in its sense it's it's
it feels like a baby into the young that
is the tic-tock feed that you were just
describing yeah yeah with the purchased
by the palate anything have it uselessly
sit in the garage that was our sort of
up into the right infinite growth model
for the last few decades of capitalism
problem is we've reached I think an end
state of that where a lot of unintended
externalities and side-effects of it I
think about it the nature what grows
infinitely forever only cancer until he
kills the host organism
I had argued manatees now the cancer on
planet Earth growing out of control
mindlessly I think actually that's why
we had a fascination with zombie movies
and TV shows that was basically a
metaphor for ourselves on this endless
consumption path the Walking Dead is us
right and so I think we're looking more
towards maybe a better model for that
and I feel really grateful that actually
some of our biggest hits at Mayfield
have been more on that regenerative
model about reuse reshare in recycling
reselling you know companies like lyft
companies like Poshmark which is about
reselling training buy sell trade your
existing fashion as opposed to just go
buy more new stuff and I want to find
more example
of that I want to believe that you can
do well by doing good
and if we have a better than words far
of these newer models it will lead to
better outcomes right and so maybe we
can prove that maybe we can define new
you know key performance indicators KPIs
we can find new definitions of growth
and value and wellness beyond just units
produced and sold profitability
shareholder equity value you know that
kind of thing right so that's sort of
what I feel my mission is these days is
to use these platforms use these systems
but try to transmute them find maybe
better more intentional ways to do them
um
Mayfield we came up with our North Star
logo here which was people first and
what that originally meant was focus on
the entrepreneurs you know building the
companies they are the people they're
the first and foremost focus even more
than the tech even more than you know
the specifics of the product or service
or or other things they're what I'm
realizing there's another meaning to
people first which is does this serve
the people first and foremost
is it good for people not necessarily
even profitability oh okay that means
that in many ways leads to this point
which is if we look at
the way that you were just describing
the process of how we've grown the last
couple of decades in places like the US
we've had this phenomenon where median
male income flatlines while GDP
skyrockets and then we see that 50% of
all new wealth is going to the top one
percent and we're very curious as to
what has happened in our social fabric
that is creating that phenomenon whereas
in a phenomenon like nature we see these
beautiful trees behind us and we know
that the trees that sequester me more
carbon distribute them through their
networks and fungal networks the
seedlings into smaller trees that don't
so much so that mechanism is missing
from our wealth creation but also our
idea of moral ethical philosophical
spiritual evolution being missing as
well in the sense of the people first
mentality of it may feel that being
missing where it's just I just want to
be selling something so that I can self
deal when we look some more like the Bay
Area here where we're at it's almost as
though we don't even think twice about
when we have such wealth we do things
like purchase a tenth property because
of a diversified portfolio that wants to
include real estate but as we sort of
look down top-down at this board game of
Monopoly and we buy these properties all
of a sudden those thousands of people
that are on Craigslist looking for
$1,000 a month bedrooms inside of the
houses and those people are usually
artists or entrepreneurs or other people
that are trying to express themselves
they can't fit into the Bay Area anymore
so there's a there's a deep level of and
we're now we're talking about inequality
on just like the US side we're not even
talking about 50% of people that still
make less than three dollars a day which
is the cost of a cup of coffee out here
so there's levels to this there's
there's there's potential speciation
that's all
happening with people that are able to
you know take airplanes and travel and
people that are still trying to find
their next source of food or water and
so where does that where where does that
melting pot how do what are our
redesigns inclusive stake holdings are
very interesting which about that okay
yeah that's gonna go there because
joonyoung has always talked about a lot
about inclusive stakeholder how I'm
really doing my best to learn about how
do we implement that right something I'd
love to help redefine is who is on a
capitalization table who our equity
orders begin with right now we have a
model where stakeholders are basically
just investors and employees right but
if we really want an inclusive state
holding every company touches more than
just customers investors and employees
it touches mother nature it touches you
know future generations that touches all
these other stakeholders are not
represented at the table could we update
who is at the table what stake holding
is to include that I had my way we would
have mother nature represented you know
as part of the equity count table Paul
stam insist on that I think he's that
company's where he's assigned part of
the cap table to nature itself and maybe
nature is represented by you know a
leading nonprofit or some or a group
like that that is the domain expert that
could be a good steward and voice of
that of that stakeholder you know that
was one or two because the two models
were corporations there are compensating
these nonprofit representatives of
stakeholders like nature and that's a
new revenue stream for them so many
nonprofits are not just in the death
trap with him to raise money from donors
all the time
I could symbiotic that way and other set
of stakeholders will be future
generations right would future
generations be able to be represented at
the table as well you know I'm really
interested if the grete Thunder if so
the world could have voice to kind of
say hey corporation don't use up all the
resources right now so that like nothing
exists for us to have a world in 50
years you know that sort of thing so
that notion no more inclusivity and
expanded you know can i stake holding
there I got to be really interesting
because you know these corporations and
companies startups we don't exist in
just a vacuum of our investors and
employees there's all the other elements
we touch and they should have a voice at
that table historically many empires
have been built and centralized on the
backs of slave class labor right and
what I was talking to Tom Qi about this
and you kind of point out to me you know
last century we began with essentially
tech augmented strip-mining at scale of
natural resources this century's tail
and we started with so far it's strip
mining at mass tech enabled scale of
cognitive resources and these cognitive
resources the mass population is the new
slave labor class building up the AI
capabilities the proprietary data pools
of these mega platforms like Facebook
Google and whatnot we get these sort of
free addictive services in exchange for
our giving up the sovereignty and
ownership and rights of our data and
behavior right and that's probably not a
fair trade really in the long run and
many of us don't even realize the cost
of that trade right now so I do think at
some point we're going to need a
cognitive and data Bill of Rights for
these sorts of things and that is
something I've been working on with and
I'm goes a li a jack Kornfield some
others on this mobius open compassion
project kind of dreaming of what would a
what would a pledge of ethical values
ethical design principles for tech
companies look like what how might it
read thou shalt not intentionally
addicted a lake users sovereign over
your own data you know things like that
because I think that's what it's time
for Silicon Valley to step up to do you
know this is much of what dressed on
Harris has been ringing
alarm bells on so the the designing of
the social fabric for inclusive stake
holding for unleashing the inner artist
in every single one of us to the
symphonic potential that could unfold is
seems to be what not only yes Silicon
Valley but also that Hollywood or that
the relationship between the US and
China or that if you take like a
biometric consciousness signature of
someone like Jeff Bezos and try and like
see that compared to like the Dalai Lama
and just see you know really what is
what is going on do people really care
about the environment being a
stakeholder at the table of their
company like what would it look like to
have that example where mother nature
may be represented through one of the
twelve indigenous tribes that went to
the United Nations to try and speak
about about this maybe maybe one of them
is literally on the board at at Amazon
yeah right
so do they do think how would that work
out you guys yeah a couple thoughts
there um I still believe that for-profit
markets and and companies are the best
way to drive change mmm if leadership at
the top and the employees have that
intention that mindset they can pattern
model these new behaviors which I hope
then creates positive peer pressure for
other companies to want to do that
eventually I do think we need to upgrade
how Wall Street investors entrepreneurs
even measure what success is and will
need basically new metrics of economics
anyway a couple thoughts later later to
share but the first one is that I think
I'm really interested to see would we
have more conscious and awaking of
leaders captains of industry because
they could drive change top-down you
know as
become more in tune I think with their
their own connection with nature with
others with and the role of
responsibility as a leader and second is
employee activism I thought was
brilliant seeing so many employees at
Amazon signed petitions to say hey we
need to participate in this I think that
probably drove a big part of why Bezos
did sign that pledge for you know sort
of being more carbon neutral as a
company I'd love to see more employee
activism at scale
you know decentralized and automated to
basically raise a megaphone in mass to
their leaders say hey we want to see
more corporate action more
intentionality here from the top and I'm
really curious have you heard of the
three and a half percent effect there is
a well-known set of TED talks from a
couple of speakers that that showed that
to get successful nonviolent sort of
revolution and activism and change that
you only need three and a half percent
of a population to do something like a
coordinated climate strike or protest or
whatever it is to cause change new
zealand recently i think was one of the
first countries to hit that three and a
half percent with a climate strike where
people students would stay home from
school workers would stay home from work
and apparently that three-and-a-half
percent don't meet though you need to
really start to bring an economy to its
knees and that's when you can really
drive some change there's some really
keen to see would more employees start
to form this kind of you know kind of in
mass decentralized activism hopefully
without you know kind of threat of being
fired or being retaliated against right
but could that drive more change in in
corporate leaders to step up I'm also
very encouraged one of my company's
Grove collaborative the CEO has said
we're gonna be a B Corp from the start
to the end as much as possible and
they're one of our breakout hit
companies if they can succeed with that
even go public as a B Corp you know
there'll be one of the largest examples
of a startup that scaled to that size as
a B Corp and I hope that would set a
good example for others so we need a
model these new behaviors for others
create that positive peer pressure drive
that top-down change as well as sort of
you know kind of harnessing and
empowering employees from the bottoms up
activism
as well so I really do want to see that
cuz companies can be forces for good you
know especially if they're mission-based
and have that pledge from the start
to have this do well by doing doing good
then start to bake in these things like
inclusive steak holding you know broader
sets of growth metrics and value metrics
beyond just profit or shareholder value
yes so I think that's the era that's
gonna come next it's your point though
how we change behaviors otherwise in in
the masses oh this is going to be a bit
of a downer but I've come the conclusion
that in many ways it's too late we we
are too late to prevent climate change
in fact if anything I've I think I'm now
a collapse inist meaning there are many
aspects of climate collapse which are
already going to come which are already
inevitable we're gonna start to see more
of these wildfires and extreme
hurricanes and whatnot and we're going
to see more and more places be
uninhabitable and it's going to lead to
patterns of change and we're
Freshwater's available and we're what
types of food can be grown huge shifts
of value wealth transfer in terms of
real estate development you know kind of
the services and investment
some studies show we have a 1011 years
to start you know making those bets now
and I've talked to Bruce Damer about
this he's McCain climate moonshots but
picture in these next 10 years people
placing their bets on what the world
will look like post climate collapse and
those folks with that prepared for it
with the right kinds of infrastructure
or investment and reallocation of
population and infrastructure will lead
to a post climate collapse bifurcation
of you know haves and have-nots and
picture the mass national migrations and
refugee movements of those places that
did not prepare for that you know entire
evacuations of cities and maybe even
countries they fled to other areas and
you could imagine the ensuing war of
those that were the haves that invested
in that infrastructure now defending
themselves against to have-nots hordes
coming in so this could be a really
bleak dystopian future and I hate say
but I think parts of those elements will
kick in and when I really zoom out
there's also a part of me that kind of
says from a detachment standpoint yeah
maybe that's the way it's supposed to
play out
human beings were sort of herd animals
by nature maybe we need the [ __ ] to
really really hit the fan before we do
something about it and maybe we'll need
to see climate collapse really kick in
before action takes place that's been
the history of humanity we typically go
through periods of like mass mass you
know kind of like collapse before
periods of prosperity
maybe that's what needs to happen if you
really do mout and take that Kevin Kelly
you know tech Neum kind of future -
who's to say our job as a species maybe
it's just to reach the next rung of the
evolutionary ladder it's maybe Homo
Digitas or homo silica or whatever we
want to call it maybe we're like horses
maybe were a peak humanity you know what
was it
Peak horse was twenty three million or
something like that and now there's only
a few million horses around maybe with
climate collapsing as are the effects
who's to say to three billion people is
better for planet Earth
then then eight nine billion right so it
does lead to some big questions and part
of me kind of thinks that nature is a
pretty resilient system you know mother
nature will self balance with or without
us I hope that it's with us and that
we're intentionally on that boat I'm
trying to get there but you know it
it'll all be it'll all work out the way
it's supposed to in the end a lot of our
discussions we've been talking about how
do we design for humanity thriving if we
take a mother nature view one of best
ways for mother nature to thrive is
maybe less humans it's a pressure cooker
in many ways it's a perfect pressure
cooker and there is so many different
ways of viewing the pressure cooking
evolution of consciousness that's
happening where you have the good and
the evil that are just constantly sort
of at at play as it levels up where you
did paint out this very time to
dystopian side yet there's also this
other side of piecing together the right
evolved ways of our way that we engage
with each other in our environment where
it can actually be around making
flourishing for for unleashing the inner
artist and all of us so those two things
kind of like it kind of it does kind of
take me to this idea that yeah it's it
is it is perfect it's been perfect it's
going to continue being perfect but it
also kind of takes me to this idea of
being off of perfect as well meaning
yeah it can be seen as perfect to have
this grand challenge of controversy
where we have so many people that have
so little and we have so many people
that have so much and then that makes it
perfect but then there's also this other
view of perfect which is where people do
have their basic needs being met and the
symphonies being played out where people
aren't going home to sleep on piles of
cash and other people are going home to
sleep on concrete I agree and what I
fear is that the system's the business
models the the way we've set up the game
today
leads to centralization of wealth
especially when you look at exponential
effects of real-time feedback loops ai
optimization proprietary data sources
and these sort of mega platforms what I
fear is that the inescapable conclusion
is the mass majority of wealth will end
up in the hands of like a dozen people
because with network effect type of
businesses and platforms that's what you
get to ultra centralization well
historically though to when there's too
much singing happens when you play the
board game Monopoly that's right and the
thing is though historically though when
there's that much inequality gap
eventually some mass revolution occurs
and you know it Wars and all that sort
of thing and so that be the equivalent
of like you know people playing Monopoly
over and over until like the players who
keep losing like screw this game this is
stupid they flip the table up and the
pieces go flying right you know so it
could be very similar there as well I
think this you know these these these
tensions will continue to
we're seeing that America is now not one
country we've got this you know
bifurcated tribalism happening and you
know it's gonna like you said pressure
cooker that's gonna keep going but many
of us will kind of keep chugging along
and trying to build unicorns here in
Silicon Valley but what I'm encouraged
by there's more and more of us I think
waking up to these issues of inequality
and wanting to examine at the root
fundamentals
maybe these play books aren't the right
ones maybe we should up level those
those are the discussions I'm most
interested in I don't have the answers
and I don't want to seem like I'm not a
soapbox preaching and I I am just trying
to do my research on what are the
alternative models out there where can
service truly that people first helping
people would be baked into the mission
of businesses where can nonprofit or
hybrid business model kind of dynamics
merge with for-profit could for profits
do more on this be court form of
formation of principles can they do more
tithing or we're giving back and can
nonprofits incorporate more best
practices of for profits and how they
perform and their models so they're
sustainable without just begging for
donations all the time are there ways to
do this yes and keep keep you know kind
of upgrading the the firmware keep
exploring new hybrid new models be on
the side of the good and be on the side
of constantly trying to level up the
good for all these different variables
in the equation yeah and you know we
started the podcast was basically
refined the questions keep questioning
the system and try to explore and build
new models for the future so that even
includes questioned how capitalism is
implemented today question how state
cooling is done today question how
Silicon Valley works today
and it's it's changing I think it is
shifting and it's finding a new flow
beautifully yeah that's a really good
cover of most of what we wanted to
discuss on the program constantly being
in this Wow a moment-to-moment Wow of
the reality that we get to
immerse ourselves in and be here sharing
and when we when we live in our ego or
our identity we we don't get to maybe
experience that wow as often as when we
don't and so to be practitioners of the
drop rejoining the ocean on a moment
moment basis can help us with being in a
state of wow yeah my it's gonna sound
morbid my favorite keyhole into that has
actually been death and dying
so something I'm interested in is how do
we from reframe the perception the
culture of the context around dying
death is such a taboo topic in society
it's something nobody wants to talk
about that's why catches so many
families off-guard when when it kicks in
right I this last weekend I did a
training to be a death doula which is
someone who helps hold space for the
passing of somebody it's like a birth
doula actually but for the passing the
exiting of a soul as opposed to the
bringing in of one and the practices the
intentions the the rituals in that death
doula process I think really could
inform us of how to found and find that
Wow in each moment and is it's a it's a
beautiful area I encourage people to
look into it and it was something that
was remarkable to me because in a lot of
these things like meditation or when
when there are people doing psychedelic
peak experiences you know that everyone
talks about ego death for me I've always
thought these are actually opportunities
to rehearse your eventual physical death
and in that moment your mind will be
panicking that loss of like identity
your body will be screaming and fighting
to just stay alive another moment
because that's what this program to do
and it can be sheer terror or it could
be this graceful acceptance of I'm
graduating and so I kind of think a lot
about perhaps we we've this cognition of
death more and more in tour every day
and knowing how to die well perhaps
gives clues of how to live well that's a
really good doorway to this Wow
you know
the practices you'd you helped foster as
a death doula is a lot about weaving
meaning finding a through line of your
life creating rituals and legacy
projects and and these sorts of things
which really I realize we should be
doing this all the time even while we're
healthy and living those are how you
spot the Wow in every moment you know
and and so it there's so much good stuff
if you just pay attention like just like
you know the pattern on your shirt the
beauty the rose petals are like you know
how deeply you can go down the rabbit
hole of just focusing on one breath you
know like there's there is so much to to
notice and be present with you know
sleep is a brief exercise and - mmhmm
yeah and I like how you talked about
death and birth doula something that's
very interesting and dying preferences
is interesting it's so taboo that I
can't tell an urban metropolis that I
don't want to go into your hospitals
upon upon my time of passing I want to
go out to the beaches or to the forests
and I want to be out there with some
people and that's how I want to pass and
I want to be buried there and like it's
just like no you can't you must be you
must be in this hospital the extension
Airy system plus cemetery afterward or
it's just it's very important to talk
about dying preferences and yeah and
also just it's gorgeous seeing when the
child comes into the world and when the
person is leaving the world and these
states have in between that right we're
in now which end to have our perspective
along mented it's all about perspective
so if we can augment the lenses at which
people see reality with a deeper drive
towards the the nature of it
the beauty right yeah I think so you
know there's that saying like oh you can
see glass is half empty and or half full
but there's another perspectives holy
[ __ ] there's a glass and it could be
even be filled right so my favorite
exercise tap into this
we'll just picture yourself on your
deathbed and in your imagination that
moment that you could be granted a wish
to just go back to relive one day of
when you were thriving and healthy and
right now is that remembrance actually
that that wish granted while you're
actually on your deathbed kind of can
shift your focus quite a bit to write it
all so for me right now it took me to
wondering what day of my life is been my
best day and why is it that we don't try
and make it so that every day is is like
that yeah rather than yeah the journey
itself rather than the trophy I want it
I want to ask hmm could we may be a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence very possibly so who's to
say homo sapien is supposed to be the
ultimate wrong on the evolutionary
ladder that's egocentric don't you think
that could be pretty my Opik as well
right
again perhaps we are a bootloader to the
next step of the evolutionary ladder
what kind of seemed to make sense it's
the same supposition that makes me kind
of laugh is like why would we assume
reality is bound to three dimensions in
time in one direction yeah you know yeah
remember that that story flatland right
or flat world or sorts or like to a one
dimensional being you know like a two
dimensional line seems or a two
dimensional space will always just kind
of look like that line right and then
two or three dimensional being things
look like 3d objects but I think back to
simulation I think we are a simulation
of 4d beings trying to figure themselves
out by modeling things in 3d because
what do we do we try to figure ourselves
out of modeling ourselves in these 2d
types of surfaces right and then four
dimensional beings are themselves
simulations of five dimensional beings
trying to figure themselves out and on
and on and on up and down the ladder
what's that Turtles all the way up and
down and then how about what do you
think is most beautiful Wow
this is gonna be so trite but it's love
it's love the the kind of love where you
want everything for somebody and nothing
from them you know the first time I
tasted that really was being a parent
you know the love a parent can have for
a child or man those moments when you
know you're really in love with a fellow
human being and just for all their flaws
and their quirks and everything and and
and you love them not just in spite of
that buddy even for that right and man
that's probably the the core of beauty
and a lot of it really starts with self
love you know that's the doorway to have
capacity for infinite love for everybody
what I kind of think of is what if God
is that part of ourselves that has that
capacity to have this perfect love for
another being we often experience it as
parents that that I would give my life
for this this other being but what if
God is that capacity within us to have
that same intensity and depth of
compassion empathy and love for all
beings for for all nature of everything
else around us you know a vast infinite
sort of sea of all-encompassing love
yeah I'm sure we could riff for another
couple hours there's so many cool rabbit
holes to go down but thank you for the
work you're doing on this these are
wonderful questions wonderful things to
ponder and wonderful things to take with
us as we move through the world thank
you thank you thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking across all the different things
that Tim was teaching us we'd love to
hear from you check out the links in the
bio below his mayfield profile also
Twitter Instagram LinkedIn go follow him
go check out that was pages also do have
more conversations with people online
your friends families co-workers about
all these different subjects support the
artists the entrepreneurs the leaders
around the world that you
and support them and help them grow you
can find all of our links to our show
below on paypal patreon cryptocurrency
join us during the movement and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank for tuning in we will see you
soon thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]